c'est ce qu'on appelle un homme de
l'ombre c'est un personnage discret qui
fait l'objet de bien des fantasmes mais
qui êtes vous monsieur buisson mais qui
êtes-vous patrick buisson ancien
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
la première fois qu'on le retrouve dans
les archives c'est ici en
c'est lors d'un rassemblement du front
national dont ses mains un livre
consacré à jean marie le pen dont il est
l'auteur proches du front national donc
il est aussi rédacteur en chef du
journal d'extrême droite minute un
journal hebdomadaire d'opinion comme
minul tu devrais peut-être la propriété
de ses lecteurs après minute il passe
par valeurs actuelles puis intègre un
média davantage grand public lci depuis
cinq six ans en france on voyait man
monté dans toutes les enquêtes le thème
de la sécurité
de moins en moins journaliste patrick
buisson devient l'homme de la
réconciliation des droites en 2007 il
quitte les plateaux télé et devient
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy alors
candidat à la présidentielle il doit
l'aider à gagner des voix d'extrême
droite
comment est il devenu l'influent
conseiller assis à la droite du
président sarkozy
fin connaisseur des médias aujourd'hui
directeur de la chaîne histoire après
plusieurs années sur lci et cultive
depuis 2007 la rareté médiatique
laissant son nombre suscité toutes les
spéculations celui sont jean françois
copé bout de son nez dans la campagne de
l'ump
une fois l'elysée il devient son
monsieur sondages nicolas sarkozy aime
sonder l'opinion un peu trop au bout de
la cour des comptes qui cet été épinglé
l'elysée sur le montant de la facture
sondages c'est la paire dit des sondages
de l'elysée en tout plus de 9 millions
d'euros dépensés pour des études
d'opinion sans qu'aucun appel d'offres
n'était passé des sondages facturés
notamment par patrick buisson l'un des
plus proches conseillers de nicolas
sarkozy qui avait bureaux ouverts à
l'elysée la justice a ordonné
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
pour favoritisme c'est là tout le
problème le favoritisme ces études
commandées par l'elysée sont réalisés en
partie par l'institut que dirige patrick
buisson publifact et facturés au prix
fort bénéfice estimé à 1,4 million
d'euros pour favoritisme détournement de
fonds publics et abus de biens sociaux
patrick buisson encourt 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et 375 millions d'euros
d'amendé
[Musique]